The Joe Rogan Experience there's there's
some weird thing about human beings
where they they gravitate towards a big
leader but towards someone who claims
they have the answers and seems very
confident and can speak reasonably well
there's almost like a cheat code where
people just like they get locked in it
feels like order it just feels like
order if you go if somebody says I know
and they're tall
if first of all if they're tall that
gets you like 60 of the way there that
helps if they're tall and says I know
what we should do huh
charismatic good looking fit
uh attractive to women like that'll it
just makes you feel like Daddy's here
some daddies here a different Daddy it's
like oh all right that's what people
like about Trump that's what people like
about Obama any most presidents are some
form of that yeah what Reagan yeah uh
certainly two termers
George W bush in a weird way
form a day you know what I mean like
it's sort of he George Bush George W
bush
guy walked like he had a [ __ ]
two foot [ __ ]
guy walked like he had he had to leave
room for two dicks that's how wide his
gate was and he said he used to practice
it he practiced it George W bush used to
practice you look it up yeah he would
talk about in interviews
walking around your house practicing
your impressive walk yeah well that can
you imagine anyone more than him doing
it it's like the exact guy that would do
that like a practice walk
um yeah
uh Bush's renewed confidence this is
2005. some folks look at me and see a
certain Swagger which in Texas is called
Walking that's how President Bush
described himself during his acceptance
speech at last year's Republican
National Convention in New York City but
for much this year the president seemed
to have lost the okay
that's just yeah but I've seen other
interviews where he talked about talked
about actually practicing his walk
well they're originally from Maine you
know they're like kind of fake Tech come
on Joe yeah they were from Canada no I
know they're like they couldn't be more
Blue Blood yeah his dad George Bush
Senior was head of the CIA yeah yeah
yeah which is weird now I wonder if that
would help him now
politically
I was the head of the CIA
uh didn't hurt him then didn't hurt him
but only one term yeah but that was
because of uh what's his face uh yeah
yeah
I'll tell you what's wrong
that guy he [ __ ] threw the whole
thing out the window like when he bought
television at time like Prime Time
television time I was like I'll just buy
the whole hour and gave the networks
money so they could run his speech and
talk about how you're getting [ __ ] by
the IRS people at home are like what the
[ __ ] is it literally was like one of the
very first internets yeah absolutely
yeah he made himself go viral and he
appealed to people that were not
there's like a whole part of the country
that's not spoken to Yeah by
I mean mass media you can call it
liberal media I don't even think I think
there's like a level
that they just people just don't want to
talk to them it's like people that
that aren't especially rich or
sophisticated or any of the stuff that
people think is great and they want to
that Advertiser won't appeal to
they just and then Ross bro was like
look here yeah and it's like a beacon
for people it's like a siren song people
are like what what's that this guy and
that by the way a billionaire
and it's not about people think it's
about
he didn't seem like a billionaire that's
the that was his like that's Trump's
appeal too like he doesn't seem like a
rich guy he's a regular guy that's funny
like Dr Oz lost how because because
he seemed he seemed like a liberal
fetterman seemed like a conservative he
but because I think so much of it is
just looks
you can speak to this yourself people
are against you because you're fit
there are people that are like [ __ ]
Meathead I'm like he's not a meathead
[ __ ] yeah he is it's because you look
you just are you're people wouldn't
believe that you and I are friends you
know what I mean like we're like a it's
like when a turtle hangs out with a
[ __ ] python
[Laughter]
the turtles is right in the top of a
python people go like holiday it's like
we're we're uh unexpected animal friends
um the uh so I just think it's so much
of it as looks so much it's a lot of it
is right way more than people would have
saw the fetterman debate would go oh
this guy needs help couldn't watch I
literally couldn't watch it I knew like
that's gonna
it would it feels cruel or something it
is cruel it's cruel to put a gun in a
position like that who's recovering from
a stroke you're not supposed to be into
that kind of stress